all right let's jump into this first
story we got this from politico
pelosi taiwan trip overrides chinese
military threats military and diplomatic
efforts limit beijing to angry bluster i
mean simply put we only need the first
opening paragraph here house speaker
nancy pelosi will visit taiwan on
tuesday decisively ending weeks of
wrangling between the united states and
china about whether she should make the
trip pelosi's controversial stop in
taipei which would make her the highest
ranking u.s official to visit the
self-governing island in decades
indicates the pentagon has downgraded
its assessment of a potential credible
chinese military threat to the speaker's
safety beijing has strongly protested
pelosi's taiwan visit and issued lurid
warnings of a stern chinese response
quote a visit to taiwan by her would
constitute a gross interference in
china's internal affairs and lead to a
very serious situation and grave
consequences chinese foreign ministry
spokesperson zhao ligian said monday
i'm assuming you guys saw as well you
had that guy from global times basically
say we'll shoot her plane down so i'm
wondering i got a couple questions why
do you think she's going
is the threat really
is there really a threat
or is the world war three stuff just
people posting it because it gets clicks
well once she announced she was going
she had to go because when china reacted
the way they did uh the speaker the
third ranking person in our government
the speaker and the united states can't
can't be bullied to going to a
an allied country
because of china china is the
is the big threat to our to our country
it will be for
uh
for my lifetime and probably a lifetime
everybody listening to this podcast uh
china is a serious player we don't take
them as seriously as we should and and
uh and i'm very happy to i'm very
surprised i don't agree with nancy
pelosi on anything but i i agree that
she should go to taiwan i'm glad she's
going to hawaii why i don't know why
she's going but i'm glad she is and i'm
i'm glad she stood up to the chinese and
is going tomorrow yeah what do you think
mark yeah you know i get a lot of
fundraising texts from politicians on
both sides of the aisle
it's a great fundraising ploy for nancy
pelosi i mean really you're going to see
texts about this about how she's saving
the free world and so i think part of it
is a political play and she's trying to
set herself aside from the biden
administration they're going to get
their
backsides handed to them in this
election and i think she wants to be
able to blame biden and separate herself
from that really
is she she's running for re-election
she's going to keep going how old is she
she's 18 83 she's already been she's
been embalmed already so she can go for
a long time she's older than i thought
she was i thought she was just shy of
80. she's 83. i think i could be right
yeah i think that's correct i think
that's right yeah i mean crazy old i
think there's a problem we have in our
government in general that people just
serve literally until they pass away and
it's never the way it was intended to be
i think this is one of the fundamental
problems in our country i'm worried
about military conflicts especially with
china and i wonder why it is because you
know rick you mentioned china's the big
threat i think
i agree absolutely why is it russia 24 7
on corporate press mainstream media
democrats even a bunch of republicans
just scream russia all day well because
russia attacked ukraine i mean no one
was screaming russia i mean
trump in russia and the russian
collusion well everyone was screaming
russia because of russian collusion but
they weren't they weren't concerned
about russia as a great threat to to the
country
china is the great threat and and
candidly we made china the great threat
we we had a policy which by the way i i
was supportive of an and and
thought at the time it was a viable
policy which was to try to engage china
try to bring china into the 21st century
and uh and you know build up capitalism
within china and markets and and that
that would move china toward uh
a more peaceful and free world
all we've done is
arm arm them with
many more resources than they would have
ever had they stuck in their
old pre-market days and made them a real
threat we have to we have to start
acting differently that's a whole nother
discussion but we're not doing enough to
confront china right now do you regret
your position yeah well do i regret it
it's
was it a was it a good idea was it a
viable option it hadn't been tried
before and and you can say well we tried
it it didn't work was i hate i hate
going back and said well you know i it
was a bad idea well no it was actually
an interesting idea could it have worked
maybe with a different leader in china
maybe with different i don't know but it
didn't work you know i think we just
have to recognize it didn't work there's
a long-term misunderstanding of
americans of culture internationally i
think we're very ethnocentric we have a
western cultural view the idea that you
were going to take a country with a 3
000 year history and change their view
of themselves in the world you know they
call themselves the one sun there's only
one sun in the galaxy and that's china
they've always believed that and so i
think it's just and i think we do this
i'm not pointing at you in particular
but i think we do this as a nation that
we look at other countries and we think
oh they have the same aspirations as we
do you know they want to be part of the
world community that was never china's
aspiration i'm not saying i understood
this back then i'm saying in hindsight i
think we need to look at the world more
realistically where are they actually
coming from what's their history what do
they really want now not what can we do
what will they do if we're nice to them
which tends to be our foreign policy the
only the only thing i would say is we
have to look at it in the context of
when this happened this was basically
the 19 late late 80s and 90s
and the soviet union had fallen the the
the iron curtain had fallen and so we we
were feeling feeling our oats yes that
in fact we can affect the course of
geopolitics if you remember we books
were written the end of history right
well you know democracy and capitalism
that was going to be it
and and that was hubris but
if you look at what how things had gone
do it thanks to reagan and others who
stood up against the soviets and and and
did infiltrate them with a lot of
information about free speech and
capitalism
you can make the argument it sort of
worked now what's happened since then
has been a cluster but it is it's uh
it's it was not
in a rational thing to contemplate at
the time i think it's the inverse i
think
you had a lot of special interests in
the united states that thought you know
we could democratize china we could you
know bring capitals in there and said
what's that what ended up happening is
the weird authoritarian communist woke
stuff has been seeping into our side of
things
our movies are being edited to play
china not the other way around
yeah and i think look there's a there's
a military power raw military power what
they do in south china sea
the economic power and their
understanding of economic leverage has
been extraordinary the amount of chinese
money that's flowed into this country
it's not that hard to buy most people i
hate to say that but when when you go to
somebody and it's here's a few million
dollars and people never been able to
imagine that kind of money and all you
have to do is be nice about china censor
some stuff about china people do it do
you know the stories about how the
chinese would manipulate pows
or you know
what what they would do is
they would say something like if you
want to eat today you need to tell us
one thing that you think is wrong with
with america
or something of that effect like
whatever country they were from and they
would say something like
uh we've got a homelessness problem
right of course america's not perfect
but it's one small step at a time that's
the psychological manipulation and i
feel like we're experiencing that on a
grand scale i don't know you know we've
had we've had guests here who are
researchers on china
who tell us that we know about what they
call the 50 cent army are you guys
familiar with that no that uh citizens
of china or people like who who work in
propaganda get paid 50 cents every time
they post something pro-china or
disparaging about its enemies
so you go on social media and what
happens you go on twitter you go on
youtube for instance and you say bad
things they flag you they mass flag you
they report you you go on twitter all of
a sudden you're being inundated ratio
with people being like you're you're
wrong and you don't understand they have
these people attempting to manipulate
public opinion
i think
i think we had a lot of politicians who
really really underestimated the future
of what warfare was going to be like
yeah where
you you you took the words out of my
mouth we were at war with china and and
i know that people say oh yeah warmonger
and warmonger no no i'm not saying that
we are in fact the problem is we're not
at war with china we're not treating
china the way they're treating us the
the the espionage that goes on here that
the stealing of technology i mean it's
just it is incredible how much of of
american created ingenuity has been
expropriated to china and and yet we
allow
thousands maybe millions i don't know of
chinese to come here to go and get
educated here in our countries and and
and and bring all that technology back
here yeah oh man it's it's it's insane
we have to sort of take a step back and
say
why are we letting people come into this
country who are here to steal technology
to be educated to come turn around and
then use it against us so again we
aren't on a war footing when it comes to
china we would never during uh any pick
another period of history when when
someone was attacking us we would never
allow them to come and and
have positions of of power and authority
and education and and use it to hurt us
and we do with china and you're i think
again you hit the point a lot of it is
money i mean the fact is these
universities
need these students and want these
students because they pay cash it's also
true of private independent boarding
schools if you look at the ratio of
international students when a school is
about to go under they start really
opening the doors to international
specifically usually it's china and
korea
because their families have the money to
pay tuition they don't have to offer
scholarships i feel like in my lifetime
we've always had sort of been on our
back foot with china and i increasingly
i agree it's definitely the economic
chokehold that they have on us i mean
when the white house announced they were
gonna boycott the olympics this year it
was like well we're gonna diplomatically
what's going on with the uyghurs is
really bad so we're not gonna send biden
but also athletes don't take your phones
because they will be hacking them it's
just routine like we took this very
strange like just boycott just don't go
don't send anyone and that is definitely
a tragedy for a lot of athletes who've
worked really hard for that but
we just always placate china we don't
take this cohesive stance we always sort
of say well we're we're sort of we're
sort of against that we don't know and i
think it's just
it's so strange it's the worst part of
american foreign policy because we're
economically dependent upon them thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there